a shooting rampage has shaken a rural
community in northern Mississippi the
suspected gunman killed six people
including his ex-wife and his stepfather
deputies say the shootings happen at
three locations in arkabuckla in Tate
County President Biden said he's praying
for the community torn apart by gun
violence Dina Demetrius has the details
six people are dead after a shooting
rampage through a rural Mississippi
Community on Friday authorities in Tate
County say 52-year-old Richard Dale Crum
killed a man outside this store around
11 A.M I heard the gunshot from inside
my house Ethan cash saw the attacker
carrying a long gun and went to check on
the victim I go up to the truck where a
guy got shot at and uh I'm just I check
his pulse and everything make sure he's
okay he's he's already gone at this
point police say Crum left the store and
gunned down a woman in her home at some
point a sheriff's deputy spotted him in
a car and took him into custody after a
brief Chase but by then four others were
dead police say two were found inside a
home and two more outside near the
suspect's house in arkabutla Crum is
charged with first-degree murder and now
his own town is in shock it is such a
tragedy we have a good most people are
just really good and we never would have
thought anything like that would have
happened here Mrs Mississippi's Governor
says the suspect acted alone Dina
Demetrius CBS News